hello and welcome to this video this is
the round five coverage of the
candidates yeah let's see what happened
in in this round we've got to pull off
playing wide against kayaking let's see
what two part of did in this game we
could a queen zinian probably the
opening of the of the event at the
moment but been played in a big big
number of games and it's not something
that what could have been predicted to
easily be before it it was always clear
that this is a very decent opening for
black but it was kind of out of fashion
for quite a long time okay we see here
probably the absolute main line nowadays
black gets into this into this kind of
position and it gets it gets rather
sharp the Queen's Indian has this
reputation of being somewhat somewhat
boring opening but this is really not
the case in all lines here for example
after c5 this is definitely an
interesting position there's nothing
boring about it in fact I think there is
some slight risk here for black it's um
quite often you see other setups here
for example Bishop to be 7 and 9 a-6 is
quite often played but this was probably
two part of the idea now before as a
move quite interesting probably this
tempted kayaking to play c5 that quickly
yeah why it took and now went 95
interesting idea the night is directly
jumping into the middle of the board and
opens up there's this diagonal for the
bishop um Bishop d7 covering d5 and
Bishop f4 and the bishop to f8 now we
see that this night has
what yeah unstable position now the idea
that black hairs here is g5 and it's
quite funny to see how to Paula free
excerpt it doesn't place look to be too
the other thing as v5 is a very very
risky business for black probably not a
good one after g5 white can take on our
seven King takes Bishop g5 and this is a
very very dangerous position for black
yeah the pawn on d5 is as good as lost
and the black king is out in the open
and will probably never be safe again as
I simply know pawns so not a good idea
for black and you played Bishop to d6
and now we come to the to be honest only
really interesting moment of this game
and it's for me very surprising that to
Palo after his very bad start he he
absolutely has to win a game if he wants
to make a difference in this event and I
assembly mmm am surprised that he does
not now play a knight takes f7 this is a
playable move and it leads to it leads
to some some pretty weird complications
but I mean do you want to beat the
leader of the event or not this is a
simple question yeah so why not night f7
okay first of all what is the point that
we should look at it but let's say King
takes and now 95 is the idea yeah and
it's all about the pressure here on that
on that long diagonal how it's black
supposed to react now it's not so easy
um he cannot take here this is the first
thing this is our checks so this is
check check yeah and wide wins the house
I'm sorry this house
that's not possible what's what can like
do we can take on air form this is
definitely a possibility it's not better
than taking on d5 but still after Knight
f6 I think white should be better Queen
takes rook 61 and now yeah there's quite
a lot of things hanging so rookie 7 it's
the best movie looks a bit strange but
it is the best one and after 95 YTM is
also having the more comfortable
position yeah it's a pretty strong
double attack and yeah it continues
probably with Bishop to c5 and 97 Bishop
g2 it's very wild yeah of course it's
wild but I mean what's the pile of idea
he wants to do something and he is the
kind of player to go for some crazy
complications yeah anyway black also has
this meant that was also a possibility
um here Queen d3 is interesting
attacking this annoyed like Bishop takes
but should be force one idea and again
after something like this White has very
interesting compensation yet probably a
good position it's not totally clear but
it's just weird that he doesn't go for
it because I mean he definitely um
considers the move it's not rocket
science to see that this is a possible
at the end it's surprising that the
polyp doesn't go for that okay he went
to the three and now this this moment it
is over it was just a one-time moment
possible and now everything is ok for
black yeah black is pretty well
centralized and it's not that the next
part of the game is so uninteresting but
blackest in general active enough via
their g5 business hmm it's a bit
double-edged of course what what
kayaking did but the the point was that
when he played g5 there only was this
this square for the night and it looks
pretty bad damn f4 it's very logical to
get this into back into the game but
here black i think is reasonably solid
his pawn structure is bad but he is
active or pieces play so maybe
white-headed little little something but
it didn't feel like it should amount to
much and in the game had some
simplifications check right here here
draw was agreed I was very surprised
that the part of didn't tape on f7 not
so much because of a possible objective
quality of the move but because of the
tournament situation yeah your
tournament situation is bad you play
against the guy who just has won his
game against against our Nadia and
getting him yeah dealing a blow against
it would be cool and you get some points
yourself in them to maybe have some at
least a vague chance and he didn't go
for it um yeah the next a game um we
going to check is honored Nakamura and
this won't be a very exciting experience
i have to admit right away we have the
berlin defense as expected in a couple
of games still yeah and I camera also
seems to be very insistent on that he
plays very solid openings in that event
um the three Bishop c5 and castles yeah
and I would be very surprised if this is
kind of this is this line would be M
become the main battleground against the
Berlin because I simply cannot believe
that after black gets this night trading
that there should be anything for why
if anything it's it's the most slightest
of of advantages the thing is that quite
often the knight on c6 is not a
brilliant piece in the Reno paso in them
in the juco peon or the Italian game and
black is often happy to trade this
against White's night and this is what
Black now has accomplished I know that
this has been tried but I have a look
what happens in the game Black gets be
five in no d6a for an out interesting
move Bishop to b6 he just retreats this
to insert this move as f3 is not
possible and so this and black takes
excellent now and what exactly is blacks
a problem here the answer is there is
not yeah he has good development it's an
active bishop that's an act of Bishop
position is equal I don't tries a little
bit yeah trying to at the end prove that
black has a slightly worse pawn
structure which may be technically is
true but it just they are just too too
little of things to go from saturated a
couple of Jackson thn it was some yeah
it's all perpetual technically but close
to that yeah I think that this line him
shouldn't promise white anything and he
if he wants to do something he has to
take on c6 or place III I simply cannot
believe that this should be should be
anything I mean if anything it must be
the most tiniest of advantages ever yeah
so that wasn't very interesting let's
have a look at the next game to check
and this would be curious Whitlam
and yeah and give he goes from NIDA 3g 3
and approach that yeah like 10 years ago
was never seen on the top level but
nowadays is rather popular it's one of
those openings that in a way in many
cases gets the game going without being
tutored theoretical but then also make
sure that it's not yeah a bad love of
home prep that much swindlers replied is
um quite a good move if you play the
gruene felt which is definitely the case
was realized probably the the world's
most respected Greenfeld play and
theoretician why is that a good felt
type of move yeah we will see quickly
Bishop g2 Bishop g7 d for ya and now
black really doesn't have much else then
Knight to f6 in fact i had this position
once with black end i try to be creative
and play tonight to h6 in 92 f 5 but it
turned out to be a pretty bad idea it's
just not a very good move I think yeah
Knight f6 is better and now we get a
group felt after why place the movie
form again a few cattle Greenfeld um let
me explain a little bit about this move
water because I think it's a very
variable interesting line for black why
is that the thing is white doesn't have
that many alternatives here he has that
default proach that he can go for here
or right here and that leads to that
mentioned fear category felt note that
this is just the fing keto variation of
the gruene felt not the whole opening so
you only need to know this particular
line from the blacks perspective this is
also something that I am sometimes just
just go for with black because I feel
like it's not the most demanding liner
in the group felt and it is a playable
option even if you don't know
that well yes so why would wipe lady
form the thing is here black actually in
my book has a threat the movie 5 of
course white can play something like
castles but after a five black a thing
can be reasonably happy and he's got his
full center with black after four moves
that cannot be bad the normal wave this
precedes us something with d3 and black
goes 9710 ciggy 496 it's a reversed um
fianchetto variation against the pats
defense now yeah funny transpositions
nothing that black is particularly
afraid of so most White's players white
players perceive if I've as a threat so
they played you for the alternative is
to play c4 in this particular moment
here black has an interesting choice he
can play d4 this is the most ambitious
move trying to gain space this is
something that I played a couple of
times in tournament chess especially
when I wanted to go for wind with black
it's um trying to build up p 597 some
kind of reverse benoni know what white
comes before it can be some kind of
reversed yeah declined banco whatever at
least is interesting or black and play
e6 which is also interesting it looks a
bit funky to combine e-cigs and musics
but it's doable it's also a sharper move
or and this is the best move objectively
speaking and black and take and here
white will get the power back for
example with a check no e5 yeah and this
is a position align where black is
totally fine now he's going 97 castles
and very often we use the default square
it this is also a position that you can
compare I again with something this is
something that looks like the keto
variation against the dragon so silly
with reverse colors yeah this has been
played in the World Championship match
cards and honored in 2030 the 13 match
it was the first match this is a pretty
good repertoire against Nadia 3g three
it helps if you know the group felt as
it happens in this game so this was
mostly about the opening what I know
because it's a it's a field of a part of
the opening theory that I actually do
know from both colors ok c4 c6 Queen to
be three castles castles and now swidler
goes for a modern way to play against
the creepy 3 line yeah back in the old
days they they they played Queen B 6 and
things like that which is it's still a
line but it's not very interesting the
moon 85 is a lot more dynamic and played
here by Spindler and takes a 421 and
back yeah it's funny it looks like a
position where white has given a way to
move sand with queen bee three and back
and now it's blacks mum no it's White's
move and black has gained those moves
just a five and a four yeah is it
beneficial hard to say but it doesn't
seem to be a big problem Knight c3 was
played on tnite if for ya an interesting
but quite typical move they also have
been games with Queen a5 here that also
doesn't seem to be that bad the Queen
sometimes can go back to a 6 for example
yeah 94 and now night to d2 directly
playing against that night and 93 eggs
and three day five min c2 and now Bishop
f5 yeah this move is probably not so
precise yeah it's a seems to be better
to go with Bishop to e6
Bishop f5 there was a 4 plate if in
right now goes with you for then the
move rook c8 is good yeah directly
attacking this and this if I was
actually wrong here so after Bishop e6
white would have to play something else
and it's not so clear what is going to
do and when you can play let's a room to
be one but again Ruby 8 so what is his
move oops I'm sorry and after you should
be six yeah the computer suggest
something very very uninteresting in the
move Knight to f3 but it's probably not
such a bad idea at least after rook c8
you have a clear way of defending that
porn even though it doesn't make a very
interesting or ambitious impression so
Bishop u6 was a lot stronger after the
than this now if what gets played and
white probably is a little bit more
comfortable 97 rupee one yeah p7 pawned
gets gets traded Queenie to gets covered
I'm sorry note that why cannot play some
flashy tactic here like this and Chennai
yeah because at the end this also clean
hanging gear on thought on the white
side yeah Queenie to looks far more
logical than giving away all the pieces
rook e8 we should be three they both get
their pieces into the game and route p8
yeah it looks like white should have
some small advantage with the pressure
on the beeper on the beat porn on the B
file but on the other hand the black ken
gets any route before gets in 85 it also
shouldn't be too terrible for him yeah
the move Roxy for was now played by am
by giving it seems that d5 was a bit
more interesting it's a at least um yeah
avoiding
um simplifications that we will see in
the game after d5 why does getting that
passport and yeah maybe can support it
even with c4 yeah the engines give us
the best line for black from the capture
and then 95 I'm sorry ambition of a time
sorry one from columbia and bishop evade
um yeah something like this to try it
for blockade but yeah I think white is
definitely a little bit more comfortable
I mean it's not like blacks lost or
anything but I think white can can try
in the game and get this and now the
capture and this is a bit too simple
let's say to get anything to get
anything going Bishop f4 750 one-eyed
you find entire game ended in a draw and
I didn't quite understand why actually
because um if i'm not mistaken they
cannot draw before move 30 and this
wasn't a repetition maybe i'm wrong i
think i heard this somewhere in the
broadcast but maybe that wasn't
misinformation and there is in fact no
anti draw rule sorry if i'm wrong there
but with this game points towards not
being an anti draw rule but still i
think i heard it somewhere okay a draw
here so not so many interesting games up
to this point in Israel but we had a
really interesting game the game aronian
with white against Caruana let's see
another Queens Indian know the Benoni
yeah that's a very rare opening on the
on the very top level but koala goes for
it quite interesting yeah he
definitely wants to sharpen it up and
that's good news for The Spectator that
gets to be an interesting game yeah d5
played by aronian of course not that
this is the only move but it's the only
move that really picks up the gauntlet
96 93 and we get the starting position
where why to choose us in line um may
many lights possible Aronian has played
Bishop f4 for example in the past but
also the classic aligning with a form
yeah Bishop g7 and now a bit surprising
he goes for Bishop to e2 me this is not
very common nowadays it's a much more
common to play with age three castles
and Bishop d3 the so-called FML modern
main line but i don't think that Bishop
e2 is some there's nothing wrong with it
so what I'm trying to say it's just out
of fashion castles castles and now rook
e8 baccarat wanna this is the sharpest
move actually black in many cases goes
for something like this a six a four and
Bishop g4 this has a very decent
theoretical reputation this line Lex
idea is to trade off this bishop and
then play mostly on the dark squares um
this is also why many white players for
example yours truly likes to play a
quick bishop quick 92 for example I
sometimes play this line to avoid any
Bishop g4 business and now play like
this the position in the game actually
could be reached by that but I avoid the
Bishop g4 ideas yeah but corona is not
going for that he plays rook e8
attacking this porn 92 and now night bd7
black has a choice you can also play
night too
asics which has an entirely different
idea here black tries to play the 927 in
order to support the queenside advance
typical way to continuous now something
like this a three-night back a 494 it's
so interesting strategic battle but the
strategic means in a dynamic internet in
a dynamic way and there are many
different ideas and contradictory ideas
for both sides this is Plato ever of
course all we're known and now Aronian
goes for quincy two very classical move
known from back in the 70s for example
this is the famous position where fisher
played night aged five against Spassky
in them the famous Reykjavik match um
this this whole plan with the night age
five was revolutionary at the time
nowadays it's not yeah not not so much
of a surprise the general idea however I
think in this particular position it is
viewed with some suspicion nowadays i'm
not mistaken i didn't look that up maybe
i should have done that but i think that
this kind of idea and tending look here
and 91 and look over 93 in this kind of
area and turned out to be quite
promising for wine in any case kawana
went 95 and again now somewhat
unconventional move by a roni on the
move b3 it it makes perfect sense yeah
the bishop on be too um it's just a
somewhat rare guest in the in the modern
benoni one reason for that is that often
you'd like to have the bishop somewhere
here to cover important dark squares but
still it makes quite some sense
an interesting move now by Carolyn I
placed Bishop to g4 it's a move that I
really felt was was quite surprising um
normal conventional move even though it
looks kind of funny maybe is g fiber to
support this night yeah against possible
f4 it has been played in a number of
classical games yeah why did this
surprised me the thing is it looks a
little bit weird because isn't they have
three move that can be on rights agenda
anyway yeah that's true but well sorry
that was played f3 and Bishop back the
issue is a bit that now what somehow
doesn't have a very very good move yeah
first of all really bad is f form after
night EG for whites position is already
lost I know it sounds drastic but it is
really what it is this is a big threat
and there's also 9 txt for sometimes so
let's say 94 94 yeah just believe me
this is this is absolutely terrible
alright so f4 is not possible so what do
you play if you play this should be two
for example then 9 h 5 becomes
interesting doesn't look good yeah you
want to move the night may be here and
also doesn't look good yeah again lots
of possibilities yeah somehow f3 is not
yeah it doesn't it's not so useful so
why just took it and this is some
achievement from black usually to get
this Bishop traded the light squared
Bishop is often a problem peace in the
Benoni for black simply if you look back
here it doesn't have any good square as
you had those those are covered gee flop
rarely makes sense here it does and d7
is a typical square for nodes so a good
achieve material for Caruana that he got
traded there should be true and now a
six initiating that typical play yeah
aronian is also out for something sharp
F for back and that c4 yeah he has build
up this this great center and after this
is a typical case where right now what
is in this kind of now or never
situation if you know weights and play
some some some lame move then black will
definitely be okay so what is the lame
Wolfie it's not so easy actually to play
one let's say for you to prevent any any
pee porn business yeah black has a
couple of options but for example they
could give this check check and play
something like this and I like here
there's some pressure and also the
bishop is on deform which is not bad at
all the thing is you have to compare
this that with the attacking idea we see
in the game v5 takes an f5 this is a
typical idea in the modern minority that
has been seen hundreds of times maybe it
seals the long diagonal it's very
important yeah that bishop now is stuck
on g7 not on d4 or somewhere else and
white has this idea of opening up the F
file and some kids also the push to f6
yeah the reaction of a corona is very
logical it probably also just the best
movie 5 yes counter-strike white has
absolutely no time due to take anything
here this is not leading to much yeah
you can probably argue that this should
be terribly bad but it just doesn't
belong into this position we are trying
to take on the kingside not taking stuff
here I mean I can also take this pawn
so you went 94 that's the point yeah you
play a 5 also to open up the e4 square
for the white knight Knight b6 by Corona
trying to oops try to take this with the
night and also to undermine the d5 pawn
we see that the players accelerated
enormously white some center yes is
crumbling down but on the other hand we
also see that white has attacking
chances the knight on e4 is very strong
and that F porn is very aggressively
placed aronia now plays the move Bishop
c1 and here he had an absolutely um
fascinating alternative that he actually
considered as he mentioned in the press
conference but he couldn't really he
wasn't convinced enough to play it he
now could have basically a ya burnt his
britches in a way by playing the move f6
that's what he played but f6 was the
move yeah and this is very interesting
now first of all the move Bishop f8
looks pretty much forced yeah Bishop age
6 doesn't make much sense after Bishop
see one ya black cannot trade anyway and
why gift why to the bishop see one move
so that doesn't make much sense Bishop
f8 is the only decent-looking move
Bishop h8 is probably not a great idea
as white it's very quickly getting into
h6 let's focus on Bishop an aid which is
also clearly the most human move yeah
and now Aronian had this idea to push h4
h4 h5 just yeah give up the whole center
this is as I mentioned already beyond
repair in some way and just just go for
it I am not one hundred percent sure
about the objective
merit of this attack I have to be honest
I checked it a little bit with the
computer and it seems to be if i'm not
mistaken and the engine asst is right
and it's difficult if you just give it
to the engine on some they're like after
minute or so it just gives a black win
but if you give a gift we give it a
couple of more moves and let it
calculate a little bit longer the the
picture gets some far less far less
obvious we can look at a couple of
things and see what happens what should
black do after age form if i'm reading
the machines correctly and i'm really
just reading our lines there because
this is very difficult to do with just
just just being a human Harry there are
so many possibilities you can actually
what you should do and what I did is
feed the engine some ideas and see if it
works or not but you absolutely have to
check all lines with the computer
because um yeah just just pure human
judgment doesn't doesn't make much sense
here anyway let's have a look age five
this one's one move that I felt is
rather logical looking and this is met
by the very brutal move g-form and yeah
this turns out to be exceptionally
dangerous probably good for white I'm a
bit cautious yeah this way i say
probably the issue is black can
absolutely not take each file is already
decisive yeah for example it but this
why it takes then cannot retention and
if you cannot recapture you're in deep
trouble as 95 is a threat they're like
this oops this let's say just check
checkmate and this is a quick way to end
things a black cannot take but you can
play Queen yourself this is far more
interesting an interesting thing is
point is that if white captures and this
is what he does he takes Queen here 22
that black actually cannot afford to
trade queens after the green trade
blacks position is probably beyond
repair something like this is directly
losing due till unitech white the tech
is still strong even without quits now
here taking king and group g1 is the is
the threat and this is almost a meaning
that the only thing that black can try
as maybe Nyjah form it's a lot throw
tougher but after Bishop see one black
hasn't gained that much you know he's
still faced with this threat you can try
like this check but it doesn't look very
convincing for black and there maybe
maybe even ways to improve yeah it's
remarkable this is very dangerous if the
black Queen takes on h5 then 93 and
strong Queen back yeah and where it's
not like the Queen as many squares go
here this becomes rather obviously
dangerous info for for human player it
obvious for you will play out dangerous
that is I mean oops i clicked a little
bit too much there I'm sorry yeah this
this we were getting there a I wanted to
show one line yeah age five after Queen
h7 ph7 looks with rather rather we added
age five wins sir it's it's also
something that engines don't see like in
a second or so this is often a
misconception by many players that the
engines give a very reliable um
evaluation almost immediately that is
not the case if you give this position
tour to an engine top engine stock fish
whatever it will start with the slight
edge for black
first with the clear abs and slight edge
and ultimately it will show then white
actually has a winning attack I don't
want to go through all the lines now but
it is actually winning attack I mean it
is a believable believable thing to say
yeah it's pretty clear that white has
lots of attacking attacking pieces and
yeah just just believe me you can try it
a little bit yourself if you like
against against the computer yeah it
feels like h5 doesn't work what about 94
this is the the most yeah let's say
dangerous-looking move maybe from from
the wide perspective perspective
perspective I'm sorry if you look at age
formed at that whole idea because you're
not just losing the pawn you're also
losing this bond but here why the tech
is also probably decisive age five and
now what now yeah first of all I mean
black can don't take such a poner 95 is
end of game and why does just crashing
through so quickly 5m this is the move
that looks bad far yeah looks to be the
most logical and here the amazing point
is is the capture and Creed to be three
the idea is Queen H 395 mate and this is
very very serious business yeah Black
has to cover that and now the amazing
point is that Queen g3 is winning idea
being to go here and here or gin in
general go on the HR the funny thing is
if black takes now the keep move is this
if it includes very strange move but it
is it is very strong if you go to h4
instead then black can actually hold on
because 95 doesn't work
after opes here it's a different story
yep right here 95 Jack King edge one and
end of game no check amazing move
amazing Queen edge too yeah this is
unfortunately lost yeah with black takes
but other moves are not are not bad at
all I should show actually the tempest
defense I'm sorry this this and Quincy
for this is the toughest toughest
looking defense but wyd winds here with
rookie three the idea being to get the
Rukia yeah amazing what is the best yep
at least with what I came up with the
best is h6 and it seems that this should
be a draw but take all this with some
grain of salt it's it's very difficult
and very tough to to judge reliably yeah
um what why draw yeah what what you get
get to with the help of the computer is
that 95 now is a pretty cool move the
idea is to play h5 bust open the
position there takes and h5 remarkable
they're also I mean black black now
takes on c4 that's probably the best
move and why it takes on g6 yeah looks
very dangerous right there for black
yeah but don't forget what has
sacrificed the peace and it's a it's a
total mess yeah what now the computers
main line is Queen 3722 it takes and now
Absalom and it judges is this whole
situation as roughly equal I know it's a
it's crazy now King hear me and takes
and rook takes and now yeah I know I
probably will move the bishop yeah it's
it's it's a total mess it's a total mess
and there are also some drawing lines
that are possible it's very difficult
it's very difficult to even after having
used the computer extensively to
completely figure out what this is
aronian I think what I what I want to
hurt or read somewhere send in the press
conference and that he did consider the
move but he couldn't quite make it work
he couldn't quite believe it and it's
also I'm important to understand how
difficult it is in this event to sustain
a loss you know it's really difficult
the score that will be needed at the end
is probably something alike plus form
and losing a game it's really tough yeah
you have to win again to even get back
to the situation where you're coming
from and losing is is really really
tough and I understand that they tend to
site on the attempt to be on the side of
caution more often than not um yeah what
did her own you do he played Bishop c1
the idea of this movies to use the
bishop over on that diagonal
after night takes I note that this looks
super aggressive yeah he's sacrificed
another porn but the issue is after a g6
now that black now takes on f5 and he
probably I mean he doesn't have to yeah
you can play maybe something like weed
37 but this is the most logical move
problem and takes and 96 plexus has
taken what he can what he could take its
three pawns but now Bishop g5 yeah and
now queen is attacked and doesn't have
that many options if you go let's say to
d7 them then white chicks Chang and this
position is something that a human
player with limited time probably does
not want to see on the board with black
note that caruana is on fifty percent in
the situation if he risks to get go into
this position and losers it will be very
difficult for him to actually get into
this event in the first place yeah get
into this event may be wrong expression
but like getting a chance yeah so I
understand that's a very difficult
decision and it's something that I mean
you can argue that you have to risk
something yeah and at one point but it
looks very dangerous to play this
position with black computers like why
like black but this is not really
something that is so relevant for the
human perspective there you bet queen
285 Bishop back to d2 and yeah what's
back supposed to do have to go back
right Bishop g5 yeah you know that you
know probably what's coming if you don't
know the game in the first place they
repeated moves here yet this it's a bit
of a shame in a way that the game ends
here but it's still not in the logical
and too
the game I think that it's this is
something where psychology really plays
a role corona certainly at least briefly
when I considered to avoid the draw a
queen to d7 or maybe Quincy seven but it
is super risky it's really super risky
and if you have little time I don't
don't trust trust the clocks here please
they are not accurate if you have little
time limited time it's not a let's say
correspondence game where you can let a
computer run for two days then it's
super difficult to two defenders with
black and aronia now he had to do this
now he had to go for the repetition you
three pods down and he has no sensible
way of avoiding this so he kind of upped
the ante you two up to a point where he
couldn't really do anything else his
spot maybe to strike what's that f6 move
yeah but this is something we would be
very interested to learn what people
come up with if they use the computer
for like a day or a couple of hours yeah
I had limited time now to try to figure
it out and I couldn't completely yeah
come come to a conclusion that is very
very convincing yeah i think that age
six is probably best but it's it's very
difficult I mean age six after after
this I think it's pretty clear that 94 @
h5 leads to big trouble or to a loss and
this is saying a lot about the position
yeah if 94 is losing so an interesting
game still a draw but an interesting
game between Aronian and corona yeah
hope you liked this video for around
five and also make sure to watch round
six which is also released in the same
batch thanks for watching